I think these bumps just like no we
message behind it and everyone coming
together first on like clean on me and
everyone fighting together like warriors
all of it has just been like really
powerful you can just me behind the mic
singing it it's like wow this is so real
this is so intense and it's so crazy
what we're all going through right now
like we've never been through anything
like this
[Music]
[Music]
the powerful moment highlighted the
amazing Canadian camaraderie last night
on stronger together we are sending our
love and prayers out to each one of you
guys and we are going to get through
this together so love you guys DC as the
likes of Justin Bieber Bryan Adams
Celine Dion Shania Twain Alessia Cara
Ann Marie Burton Cummings Sam Roberts
Jen Arden and Sarah McLachlan you all
shine delight and our amazing first
responders as well as food banks Canada
[Music]
hello there it's Sunday night and today
marks the 10-year anniversary of the
quarantine we've been on for the last
six weeks yes Ryan Reynolds provided a
few jokes for the night while
encouraging everyone to stay at home and
why shouldn't we I mean we got to watch
the Barenaked Ladies performed with
Michael Buble all over the street again
but I gotta be patient so let's enjoy
this combination I just wanna feel you
love cuz Instagram is not enough for me